I just finished 10 radiation, not a radiation questions here.
Treatment I was doing high dose vitamin C and was feeling worse after my IV.
So this is a different person.
It's not the same person who asked that last question.
I look all you mentioned to take a break, which I have.
Yes. So is there anything else I could do to help get the radiation out of my body?
So these things, any of your teenagers, any binders, the clear binder,
any other binders that you're taking, all those things will help.
So again, nothing's going to be perfect to pull radiation on your body.
But binders, key laders, homeopaths, antioxidants, glutathione,
vitamin C, all those things are going to be the best thing to pull radiation on your body.